- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science based-tools for everyday life.
[light music]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a Professor of
Neurobiology in Ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Recently, I had the pleasure
of hosting two live events,
one in Seattle, Washington,
and one in Portland, Oregon,
both entitled "The Brain Body Contract,"
where I discussed science
and science-related tools
for mental health, physical
health and performance.
My favorite part of each evening, however,
was the question and answer period
that followed the lecture.
I love the question and answer period
because it gives me an
opportunity to hear directly
from the audience as to
what they want to know most,
and indeed to get into a bit of dialogue.
So we really clarify what
are the underlying mechanisms
of particular tools,
how best to use the tools for
things like focus and sleep.
We also touched on some things
related to mental health
and physical health.
It was a delight for me,
and I like to think that
the audience learned a lot.
I know that many of you weren't
able to attend those events,
but we wanted to make the
information available to you.
Therefore, what follows
this is a recording
of the question and answer period
from the lecture in Portland, Oregon.
I hope you'll find it to be
both interesting and informative.
I'd also like to thank our
sponsors of these live events.
The first is Momentous Supplements,
which is our partner with
the "Huberman Lab Podcast,"
providing supplements that are
of the very highest quality
that ship international and
that are arranged in dosages
and single ingredient
formulations that make it possible
for you to develop the optimal
supplement strategy for you.
And I'd also like to
thank our other sponsor,
which is InsideTracker,
which provides blood tests and DNA tests
so you can monitor your immediate
and long-term health progress.
I'd also like to announce that there are
two new live events scheduled.
The first one is going to take
place Sunday, October 16th,
at The Wiltern Theater in Los Angeles.
The other live event will take place
Wednesday, November 9th,
at the Beacon Theatre in New York City.
Tickets to both of those
events are now available online
at hubermanlab.com/tour.
That's hubermanlab.com/tour.
I do hope that you learn
from and enjoy the recording
of the question and answer
period that follows this.
And last, but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[light music]
"What are the current best
practices for post TBIs,"
traumatic brain injuries for those of you
that aren't familiar with TBIs,
"Especially long term,
multiple," ooh, "et cetera."
"Thoughts on hyperbaric O?"
I'm so glad you asked
this, Danny Morledge,
"As treatment for TBIs?"
Okay, TBI...
Now, one thing about TBI and concussion,
everyone thinks football.
Guess what?
Most of the TBI is not football.
There aren't that many football players,
they're just large so they stand out.
There might be a few here this evening.
[audience laughing]
Of course, football players are a concern
when it comes to TBI.
Most head injuries are going
to be construction workers.
Have you ever seen the
hard hats they wear?
Those, I don't even know if
they are just there for show.
It doesn't make sense.
And that we actually
have a lab at Stanford
that's focused very hard on
trying to solve this problem.
So, construction workers, car
accidents, bicycle accidents.
Portland, amazing city to cycle;
I'm frankly afraid to cycle.
You're a small moving object
around these big objects
and people are staring
into their little aperture
on their phone while driving.
I mean, whatever happened
to that by the way,
of not texting while driving?
Somehow that just disappeared.
It's like, it really has just disappeared.
There was all this science
showing that it's worse
than drunk driving.
TBI.
Well, the basic rules
of the "don'ts" apply.
If you get a head injury,
don't get a second head injury.
But that often isn't feasible
for people that need to work,
continue working in construction,
or that are struggling.
What do we know?
Well, this is a great
opportunity for me to distinguish
modulatory foundational tools
from things that directly
change your brain
and nervous system the
way that you want to.
What do I mean by modulatory?
We hear so much and
there's so many studies
showing that great
sleep, quality nutrition,
good social interactions,
avoiding chronic stress,
and on and on and on are
important for everything;
they're related to Alzheimer's,
they're related to ADHD.
I mean, we could do
thousands of podcast episodes
just returning to the same 10 things:
Sleep, don't stress too much or too long,
good social connection, avoid
toxic people, eat good food,
not too much processed food;
We could have an argument all night
and I don't want to have one about whether
or not it's mainly plants or this.
I mean, this is obviously
eating high quality food
is something that we should all be doing,
which foods you select is a
topic that is very barbed wire,
and I can give only my opinions.
All of that modulates your brain function,
but it doesn't mediate or
change anything directly.
It's setting a foundation
of what's possible.
So we should all be doing those things,
and especially people who have TBI.
Now, this question relates
to hyperbaric chamber.
Hyperbaric chamber, there's
some very interesting data.
It's essentially a
hyperoxygenation of the brain
for very brief periods of time.
I think the data on
hyperbaric chamber and TBI
are very encouraging.
The problem is, much in the
way that a few years ago,
cryo was only available in a few places.
And now people are doing ice baths
and cold showers on their own.
It's hard to find a hyperbaric chamber.
They aren't just laying around,
and they don't have
them at spas typically,
and they are quite expensive.
So, yes, there are
interesting and important data
I think on hyperbaric chamber.
You definitely want to
work with a physician
or somebody who is very skilled,
a practitioner who's very
skilled in hyperbaric chamber.
They do seem to improve brain
function by hyperoxygenating
the brain for brief periods of time.
It seems to improve a number
of things, but above all,
it seems to improve the
quality and duration of sleep,
which indirectly allows
the brain to repair itself,
because as I mentioned earlier,
brain change largely occurs in sleep.
So if you don't have access
to a hyperbaric chamber,
but you do have TBI, what
are some of the other data?
What do those point to?
Well, I'd go on and on,
and you don't have to get
this from supplements,
you can get it from food,
but this threshold level of
these EPA essential fatty acids.
There are now so many data,
so much data on the valuable role
of these essential EPA fatty acids.
Thresholds being somewhere
between one and two grams
per day of the EPA.
So much so, actually, that
there are now prescription forms
of EPA that doctors are
starting to prescribe
for people with TBI.
Although for most people
you can get this through...
You can look up and we've
done podcast episodes
about different ways to access this.
Also functions as an antidepressant;
equally good, believe it or not,
in clinical trials to SSRIs
once one gets over the one or
basically two grams per day
of the EPA.
The resident expert on
the internet about this
is pretty extreme about the dosages,
and that's Dr. Rhonda
Patrick, who by the way,
deserves a nod of
acknowledgement and support
because it turns out that
before me or David Sinclair
or Matt Walker or any of these guys
were blabbing to the world about
stuff that they had learned
in the archives of science
and in their laboratories,
the first person in was this
woman named Rhonda Patrick.
As far as I know, the first
public facing formerly trained
scientist to start going
on all these podcasts
and risk her reputation
and this kind of stuff
that you deal with when
you put your neck out
there like that.
And Rhonda's, I think, terrific.
We don't agree on everything
and it would be weird if we did,
but I think she's really
been the proponent
of these higher doses of EPAs for TBI
and for cognitive function into all ages.
"We often hear about ways
to increase dopamine.
However, are there effective
ways to decrease dopamine
when you get too much of
it for certain behaviors
or habits we want to break?"
Katie Hamm, I think is the last name.
Thank you, Katie, for your question.
Yeah, dopamine is a slippery slope.
And Dr. Anna Lembke is the expert in this,
and we've had a lot of conversations.
She's one of my closer
friends on the faculty.
Unfortunately for her,
our coffee discussions
often last four hours or more.
Her poor patients and family.
Here's the thing,
when dopamine is higher
in your brain and body,
when you've deployed it through excitement
or pharmacology or otherwise,
it tends to narrow your focus
and make you seek more of it
in that general theme that
you happen to be focused on.
It could be anything.
That's the scary thing about dopamine.
What can you do to control
it and to reduce it?
Well, for those of you
that are engaging in habits
that are healthy,
maybe that doesn't
require reducing dopamine.
How do you define
healthy versus unhealthy?
Well, I think the simplest
way to define addiction,
at least by my mind,
is that addiction is a
progressive narrowing
of the things that bring you pleasure.
And a good life is a progressive expansion
A rather simple definition,
and yet when we think about
the biology of dopamine,
dopamine is not unique to one pursuit.
It's not unique to the pursuit of sex
or the pursuit of warmth when you're cold
or cool environments when you're too warm
or food or social media,
it's just a dumb molecule that puts you
into this forward state of
mass, small visual aperture,
and a kind of obsessive-like nature.
What can you do to counter that?
Well, the best thing to do
is to not get into that state too long,
but if you do, the best
thing you can do is to try
and switch off that system,
not through pharmacology,
but by not pursuing more dopamine.
The day after a big event,
the so-called postpartum depression,
named of course because of true postpartum
after the delivery of a child.
It's quite common for people
to get very, very depressed.
There's a lot of neurochemical
and hormonal adjustments
that are occurring,
but different types of
postpartum depression occur;
after a big party, the Monday
blues, the Sunday blues,
the post-whatever blues.
The four month mark in a
relationship is typically
when dopamine starts to drop.
I always tell people, just wait.
I'm telling somebody very
close to me right now,
just wait four months,
four months, four months,
and also spend as much time
with that person as possible.
I don't know what this deal is
about not spending as
much time with people.
I think people are afraid
that the dopamine wave pool
is just going to pull them both under.
I think they've called that
the escalator model of relationship,
where you just sort of find
yourself in the relationship
because you went through
the stages without
actually deciding on them.
In any event, four months
seems to be the stage in which
the dopamine crescendo
starts to relax a little bit,
not in a long distance
relationship, however.
We know this, right?
Anticipation is dopamine,
that positive anticipation,
and there's a whole
beautiful science of this,
and I should say psychology of this.
There's a wonderful book actually.
The name of the book
is embarrassing always,
I don't know why, for me to say.
It's by a psychologist
called "Can Love Last?",
which is a psychoanalytic book
about this dopamine-serotonin system
and the kind of seesawing back and forth.
And the fact that in relationships,
people often just slam on
the dopamine side of things
and then they hit a wall
and want to break up.
Or they go into this like warm,
cozy, fuzzy feeling thing,
and they go, "Well, I guess
the exciting part is over."
And this idea that one could actually,
or two people or however
many people were in Portland
could oscillate this seesaw.
[audience laughing]
I don't think that you
want to use pharmacology
to turn off the dopamine system,
but for people that have
a hard time sleeping
and that are really in
a state of agitation
and constantly obsessing,
the psychiatrists...
One of the oldest and
most effective treatments
is that the psychiatrists,
and this does have to be prescribed,
we use a very, very low dose
of a dopamine receptor blocker,
like Haloperidol, which is
used to treat schizophrenia.
A very low dose to shut down
the obsession component.
The smart, well-educated psychiatrists
know this as a useful tool,
but this is a one time
thing with a very low dose
because having your
dopamine blocked sucks.
It does not feel good,.
But not being able to sleep
and being in an obsessive mode also sucks.
So it's actually a very
potent clinical tool.
So pharmacology is one tool,
but really at the far end of things.
I believe that one should try and modulate
their own dopamine by
not rewarding one's self
on a regular basis, but only randomly.
Random intermittent reward
is truly the best schedule
of reward, hence slot machines and so on.
And you should engage
random intermittent reward.
And I think this is also the
way that we should train kids.
I call it training kids.
You can tell I don't have kids.
[audience laughing]
You don't reward them every time.
I don't believe everyone
should get a trophy every time,
nor should you always
just reward the winners
because those winners often,
we see cases of this, high
profile cases of this,
they often crash and burn.
I mean the number of high performers
that crash and burn publicly
and Lord knows how many do
it privately is remarkable.
It's 'cause their dopamine
system is all messed up.
So random intermittent reward
is the schedule of reward
that we should impart on ourselves.
"If you had 10 minutes a day to improve
your brain plasticity, what would you do?
And when would you do it?"
Richard Conlin, thank you.
Well, I'm going to say again,
I would absolutely anchor my physiology
with morning sunlight viewing.
I can't help it.
Do you know what's interesting?
And I'll tell you very briefly,
you know what's special
about morning sunlight?
This low solar angle sunlight.
I don't think I've talked
about this much on social media
or on the podcast.
There's a group at the
University of Washington,
a couple, Jay and Maureen Neitz.
They run a lab together.
That sounds like a horrible thing,
but they do it and they
get along very well.
And they've discovered
that the cells in your eye,
the neurons that set your circadian clock
make you alert during the day
and make you sleepy at night,
and so on.
Those cells respond best
to yellow-blue contrast
and orange tones.
Now, this is important
because when you go out
in the morning, even
if it's not at sunrise,
but it's close to sunrise
or you look at the sun in the evening,
what you'll see is yellow-blue
contrast or orange;
yellow, blue, orange,
that old thing from
kindergarten or first grade.
That's not the color of light
that you're going to see
when the sun is overhead.
Now, this also is really interesting
because artificial lights,
at least to my understanding,
even the daylight simulators
have not picked up on this.
It's just about bright light.
Someone ought to design
something that can mimic this,
but nature has done
this beautifully for us.
And so viewing low solar
angle sunlight in the morning
and in the evening is most effective
because of those yellow-blue contrasts.
Now here's the really wild thing.
Those circuits that set your
levels of alertness and sleep,
yes, they respond best
to yellow-blue contrast,
but what that tells us is crazy.
What that means is that color vision
was probably not related
to color perception first
because all of that is
completely subconscious.
The pathways that do this
are present in people
who are pattern vision blind.
So, what do I mean?
I mean that color vision likely evolved
from a need to synchronize
your internal state
with the external world.
And the best stimulus in the outside world
to do that is yellow-blue contrast.
In other words, our
ability to detect color
was first and foremost, and
we understand this based on
evolutionary genomics and so forth,
to extract time of day information,
not color of fruit or color
of skin or anything like that.
That's all secondary,
which is wild and crazy.
And this is yet another example of the way
we think things work is
not the way they work.
It's completely 180 degrees opposite.
I'm just going to give
you a little teaser.
I had a guest on the podcast,
we haven't aired the episode yet.
His name is Erich Jarvis,
he works on speech and language.
He also was admitted into
Alvin Ailey Dance Company.
Again, who are these people?
He's a professor at the Rockefeller.
Anyway, I learned from Erich,
and you'll learn when
that episode comes out,
that you only find elaborate
speech and language
in species that also
engage in dance and song.
And the genomics point to the
fact that song and singing
came first and language came second.
And that led me during that
episode of the podcast,
I wrote down in my notes,
I was listening to him talk and
I wrote down in my notebook,
it's just scrawled in big letters.
It says, "I am so happy right now."
I was just blown away.
And it makes so much
sense when you hear it,
that the colors in the
sky were what our system
is trying to extract,
not a perception of
those colors in the sky,
'cause they're informing us about time
and orienting us in time.
That song and the communication
of emotional states
would be simpler and more foundational
than communication about
specific patterns of language.
When you hear it, suddenly it makes sense.
But of course we're human beings,
and unless you're Erich Jarvis
or Alia Crum or Anna Lembke,
you think about all this
stuff backwards, as I do.
"How can I navigate my way
through taking supplements
to optimize my health
when my career demands,
Army infantry, prevent me
from being able to establish
consistent routines?"
Andrew Yagen, well thank
you for doing what you do.
Andrew, so the consistent
routine thing is tough.
Here's what I can say
without going into a long
two and a half hour episode
about jet lag and shift work,
which we've done.
The most powerful way to anchor
your brain and body in time
is indeed viewing sunlight
at consistent times of day.
That's not something I made up.
We know this based on a
lot of work that dates back
to the 1930s.
The second most powerful
stimulus is going to be movement
and changes in body temperature.
In particular, increases
in body temperature
tend to make us alert,
and decreases in body temperature
tend to make us sleepy.
Body temperature drops
one to three degrees
to get us into sleep.
Why does a cold shower wake you up?
Adrenaline is released
and believe it or not,
your body is heating up
internally to combat that cold,
unless you make yourself hypothermic.
So, sauna, hot baths to get sleepy,
cold showers, ice baths,
et cetera to wake up.
Sort of obvious when you hear it,
but it's counterintuitive
because you think,
oh, heating up the body to wake up
and cooling down the body to go to sleep.
So getting into cold
ought to cool me down,
but your body compensates
just like if you threw a
cold towel on a thermostat,
you'd crank up the temperature in the room
and vice versa for heat.
Okay, so what do you do?
You want to try and use
as many of these things,
light, temperature, exercise, food.
When you eat is typically
associated with waking.
Very few of us are capable
of eating in our sleep.
And then the other one is
social activity and rhythms.
Now the discombobulated person
is going to be the person
that has not aligned these
things in a consistent way.
So while schedules vary,
and Andrew, I don't know
your exact schedule,
what I can say is if you
suddenly go from daytime behavior
and sleeping at night to
the so-called vampire shift,
as it's called in the military,
and suddenly you're up in
the middle of the night
and you're sleeping during the day,
then when you come off that shift,
what you want to do is try
and combine as many of those
same things at one time.
So it would be get your sunlight,
so go jogging without your sunglasses,
drink your coffee, engage with
other people and communicate,
eat a meal afterwards or
as the case may be before.
Try and bring as many
of those things together
at the same time of day for a few days
and pretty soon your system
will map around that.
So the reason I encourage for those of us
that are not doing shift work
to try and be fairly consistent
about sunlight viewing
is it sets in motion
everything else that's correct,
in terms of timing of
eating, appetite will follow,
when your alert will follow.
You'll start to learn your own rhythms.
When you can't control your schedule,
try and combine as many of those cues;
again, light, temperature, exercise, food,
social engagement into one period of time
and try and lock that into a more or less
a one or two hour period or
plus or minus one or two hours
at a particular time of day
for at least two or three days.
And your schedule, meaning
your internal clocks
will lock to that.
"How is social media changing our brains?"
Thomas Adcock.
Well, you hear all the terrible ways
in which it's changing our brains.
And I think that again,
we go back to this thing,
is it the aperture that we're looking at?
So is it the format that
we're engaging in things?
Or is it the content?
Well, the way I like to
think about the phone
is the way that we've been
engaging with the phone
and the laptop for that matter,
in staring into the small
visual aperture each day
is sort of like walking like
this all day long, right?
We have this amazing
ability to shuffle our feet
and take small steps
or to take big strides,
to run, to move...
I think that's the sagittal
plane for movement.
I know it for the brain,
but I always mess it.
The PTs are vicious
people online, by the way.
The PTs and nutrition people,
I've learned to just not
say anything about that.
I'm not a PT and I'm not
a physical therapist.
And they do incredible
work, but they're like,
it's a very spirited crowd.
[audience laughing]
And the nutrition thing is really weird.
I mean, it's just incredible.
People are either throwing liver at you
or they're throwing celery at you
or they're fasting or they're not fasting.
It's nuts.
In any case, the social media
and staring at a small visual aperture
is changing our brains.
Here's one way I know in
which it's changing our brains
and then I'll tell you how to fix it.
If you stare or look at
something within two feet of you
for a certain number of hours each day,
your eyeball actually gets longer.
And the visual image then is focused
in front of your neural retina,
not onto your neural retina,
and you are becoming myopic; nearsighted.
And if you look at things
in the distance enough,
guess what?
Your eyeball changes shape
and your lens will focus
appropriately the image onto your retina.
It takes some work.
Kids that look at things
up close too much,
and adults that look at
things up close too much
become nearsighted.
And there's a beautiful
set of clinical trials now
where mainly in kids,
if kids get outside for two hours a day,
getting a lot of this UVB and blue light
that we're told is so terrible for us,
but they get it from sunlight,
they actually can reverse myopia,
or reduce the incidence of
myopia, maybe even glaucoma.
Although that's a big maybe.
So, how much staring into
a small visual aperture
is too much?
I don't know.
But what we do know is that we
are literally becoming myopic
in terms of our vision
and we're becoming myopic
in terms of our cognition.
And then there's the whole business
of what's actually
contained in those Tweets
and those social media feeds
and those news stories.
Which frankly, I feel
like you lose either way,
whether or not you're
in one political camp
or another political camp,
you're upset about half of
the information out there.
So I feel like, and I'm
not someone who knows
how to talk about politics
without stumbling,
I didn't do well in social
studies in this sort of thing.
It just never made sense to me.
It just felt like the
prize goes to the person
who can shout the loudest
and the most coherently
for a moment.
But I encourage, of course,
people to be politically active.
And I vote.
[audience laughing]
But the content is tricky to navigate.
And I can't really speak to that,
except that it seems to
be bothering everybody
on one side or the other or in the middle.
And the format is something
that we really understand.
And again, I don't know of
many people that are talking
about this narrow visual
window format thing.
It came up more during the
lockdowns when we were all inside
a lot and not looking out at a distance.
The data say really to try
and get at least 10 minutes
of long distance viewing,
so longer than 10 feet away from us,
for every 30 minutes of closeup viewing.
And not a lot of us are doing that.
If you're walking to your
car looking at your phone,
you're definitely losing an opportunity.
"What new piece of neurological research
are you most excited about?
Mateo Minato.
Ooh.
I think the piece of
neurological research that I...
All right, the weird stuff.
I've got this colleague at Stanford,
Tony Wyss-Coray, and they're
really into literally taking
proteins from young blood
and young spinal cord
cerebral spinal fluid
and putting it into
older people and animals,
and they get younger.
That stuff's pretty wild.
The fecal transplant stuff is pretty wild.
You take the microbiome from
one person and as it sounds,
you transplant it to somebody else
and they take on the physical
characteristics of the donor.
It's crazy.
Until I talk to my [chuckling]...
There's some shouts for fecal transplant.
Nice.
[audience laughing]
I have never read the method
sections of those papers.
I'm actually afraid to
read the method sections.
I would say this is not neurological,
but the work from Chris
Gardner and Justin Sonnenburg,
also at Stanford,
it makes it sound like I just like,
"Stanford, Stanford, Stanford."
But these are the people I'm
closest to and surrounded by.
There are excellent places
everywhere, of course,
including OHSU and I'm not just
saying that 'cause I'm here.
I actually close colleagues
here and friends here at OHSU.
Also an amazing, although
that tram thing freaks me out,
it's like I always just
have all these ideas
about what's going to
happen if that thing breaks.
But the microbiome data
are really interesting.
I never understood why
getting your gut microbiome
was important.
And it turns out it's because
your gut actually makes
many of the neurotransmitter precursors
that your brain uses.
So that's pretty cool.
And I always thought it
would be a complicated thing
to get your gut microbiome right,
but it turns out that it's fermented foods
that seem to have the biggest effect.
There was all this argument
about fiber and yes,
fiber is important and
here I'm getting nervous
talking about nutrition,
'cause the people are going
to come at me with fiber.
But it's very clear from
Justin and Chris's data
that people who are
getting four servings a day
of fermented foods,
whether or not it's kimchi
or sauerkraut or kombucha,
that stuff actually seems to encourage
a healthy gut microbiome
and people feel better,
and their immune system works better.
And I like this because it actually,
it resolves an issue which
is that high dose probiotics,
these very expensive need
to be refrigerated things,
those actually can create brain
fog and other issues there
for real severe cases of dysbiosis.
So I always like an instance
where one can look to foods
which are good, 'cause I like to eat,
in order to resolve these issues.
In terms of other neurologic issues,
frankly, I think the stuff on dopamine
is fundamentally important.
So much addiction, that's a severe case,
but also so much waxing
and waning of motivation.
And once you understand the
dopamine system and you say,
"What activities am I engaging in
or pharmacology am I engaging in?
What am I doing to spike dopamine?"
You start to go, "Oh, I get it.
The waves in this wave pool are too high
and that's why I can't
do this consistently."
And then you do the counterintuitive thing
of approaching things with
a little less excitement,
but then you're able to
do them more consistently.
It's like, "Ah!"
And maybe with some luck, I'll
end up finishing this book
that I've been working on
for four and a half years
as a consequence 'cause I can't seem to.
"Thinking about the Wim Hof Method.
Do you believe it?
How is it really working?
What process is happening in his brain?"
Oh, boy.
Madison Cameron and everyone
here probably familiar
with Wim Hof.
Whose occupation on Wikipedia
used to be "Daredevil."
That was cool.
It's like Evel Knievel
had it and Wim had it.
I got a story about Wim.
Actually in 2016, I heard
about this guy, Wim Hof,
and I got a hold of him,
actually his children.
And I had one vacation that
year and I flew to Spain
and I spent some time
mountaineering with Wim,
which was absolutely terrifying.
I almost lost a leg legitimately.
I tied in wrong on a bridge sling.
He told me it was good for me.
He told me to, "Stare
into the lizard's eyes."
And I stared into the lizard's eyes.
I jumped backwards off this
homemade bridge sling thing.
And I had the rope wrapped through my leg
and I came back with basically the tendon
on the back of my knee exposed.
And sitting next to me on the plane
was our Vice Dean of Research at Stanford.
And I had to explain to him
what I was doing and why.
It was very embarrassing.
What did we do on that trip?
Well, a couple of things that will help me
answer your question.
First of all, when I arrived,
I suffered terribly from jet lag,
but the moment I got there,
Wim did not say hello.
He literally told me to
get into the ice bath.
And I did 10 minutes in the
ice bath not because I'm tough,
but because he held me
down in the ice bath.
He is indeed one of the
strongest human beings.
He reminds me of the bus
driver on "The Simpsons"
or the janitor, excuse me.
No, Otto is the bus driver, right?
The janitor on "The Simpsons,"
like [grunts] that guy.
That's Wim.
Incredibly physically strong guy.
What do I think's going
on with Wim Hof stuff?
Well, Wim Hof, whether or
not he understands it or not,
I always think he's sort of
the Bob Dylan of breathwork.
Like everything he says seems
to have some intuitive sense,
but you don't really
understand what in the world
he's saying.
[audience laughing]
He's going to come after me now.
We've had a good but
complicated relationship,
I'll just confess.
Maybe someday we'll resolve that.
No big scandal or story there,
just we communicate very differently.
Wim has a couple methods.
One is to deliberately hyperventilate.
This is also called Tummo breathing.
My lab actually studies this.
We have a paper that I'm happy
to share with you the results
although they're not published yet,
where people do deliberate
cyclic hyperventilation.
Which as the name suggests,
you just breathe really deeply in
and really deeply out 25 times.
Or if you're Wim, you'd say, "In and out.
In and out."
I just tell people, here's how it works.
You go [deeply breathing].
You do that 25 times and you heat up
and you feel really agitated,
and that's because of adrenaline.
If you throw yourself into an ice bath
or a cold shower, adrenaline.
If somebody upsets you
or you get a triggering text, adrenaline.
Adrenaline sounds like a terrible thing,
except when you deliberately induce it.
As my colleague, David Spiegel says,
"There's a big difference
between going into a state
and you controlling your
entry into a state."
So it's not just about
the state you're in,
it's about how you got
there and whether or not
you had anything to do with it.
States of high adrenaline
are very powerful.
When you self induce
adrenaline by cold shower,
cyclic hyperventilation,
AKA Wim Hof breathing
or Tummo breathing,
you then have an opportunity to create
a very distinct mind-body relationship.
We all hear that interoception
and the mind-body relationship.
Interoception just your ability
to sense your heartbeats
and what's going on in your body.
Powerful, right?
Terrible if how you feel sucks.
So interoception is wonderful,
but when you're anxious it
actually is more adaptive
to be able to maintain your thinking
and get yourself out
of that anxious state.
So if you're trembling and
your body's freaking out
and your cheeks are flushing
and your brain is following
your bodily state,
well, that's not good.
And if you're somebody and sadly,
this happens a lot where you've
experienced a lot of trauma
or typically this is people
that have been bombarded
with extreme criticism or physical abuse
or other kinds of abuse
during development.
They actually can seem very calm,
but internally they're
freaking out in their head.
And they're just thinking,
just get me through this.
And they just go into a state
where no one knows they're upset.
I've known people like
this and it's eerie to me
because I've never had
that response to stress,
but it's very common.
And so we should learn and
be careful about deciding
that people are in one state or another
based on their bodily or
their mental response.
Vim Hof breathing, cold
showers, et cetera,
are a great practice in my opinion,
because they allow you
to spike your adrenaline.
And you can do that, for instance,
by making the water colder
if you want more adrenaline,
staying in longer if you
want more adrenaline,
moving your limbs around in the water
will give you more adrenaline
'cause it breaks up that thermal layer.
It makes it a lot colder.
Or doing 50 deep inhales and exhales.
That is very useful because
then you have the opportunity
to use that prefrontal cortex and to stop
and sense all that adrenaline in your body
and yet maintain clarity of mind.
And that's an absolutely powerful tool.
I would even call it a power tool.
And Wim figured this out.
I don't know if you know this,
but the way that Wim discovered all this
was he was in deep grief about
the tragic death of his wife.
She committed suicide, jumped
off an eight story building.
Just truly tragic death.
And he was in situation, he
had four children at the time.
Now, he has five.
And he was in a state of depression
and he ended up going into
the canal in Amsterdam
and it was very cold and
it shocked his system.
And in that shock to his system,
which is caused by adrenaline,
he somehow was able to anchor his thinking
and in kind of genius
of sorts, Wim thought,
"Wow, I can intervene in my physiology
with this strange activity."
And then he realized that
breathing would do it as well.
You didn't have to get into cold water.
And then, years later, we discovered,
not we meaning my lab, but other labs,
that when you get into cold water,
even just 60 degree water,
that there's a very long
lasting increase in dopamine.
That is 2.5x above baseline,
which is on par with
some prescription drugs
for increasing dopamine.
So when people laugh at me and go,
"Oh this cold water thing,"
I get teased a lot on the internet.
I've heard on the internet
that I eat sticks of butter,
which I never said.
I said, "I like butter."
[audience laughing]
I've been told all sorts of things.
I've been told I eat sticks of butter.
I don't know why.
I've been told that I'm dead.
That was an interesting one.
That was one of the cooler ones.
But when I was going out
there as a serious scientist
and saying, "Using
deliberate cold exposure."
You can use all sorts of things.
Or if you come to my lab,
I'd be happy to put you in VR
and expose you to all
sorts of scary stuff.
Or we can inject you with adrenaline
or you can inject yourself with adrenaline
and titrate that, adjust
the levels of that.
So it's a very powerful tool.
And I think that Wim and
others deserve credit
for really tapping into that.
And as a last point,
there's a beautiful study
in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences
years ago using this deliberate
cyclic hyperventilation
thing; 25 breath [deeply breathing].
And then another group meditates.
And then they inject
them both with E. coli.
And the people injected
with E. coli who meditate
get nauseous, vomit, diarrhea,
and they get a fever.
And the people who
[deeply breathing] first,
far fewer symptoms, if any.
Why?
Because adrenaline actually
suppresses a lot of these
innate immune responses
in a way that's healthy
in the short term.
This is why you can work,
work, work, work, work,
where you can study for finals,
or you can take care of a loved one
and then you finally stop
and rest and go on vacation,
and then you get sick.
Stress activates your nervous
system and in doing so,
it activates your immune system.
Makes perfect sense
when you think about it.
How would we ever go through famine
if you're just getting flus
whenever you're stressed?
We can deal with a lot.
My suggestion is if you're coming off
a period of high stress,
to do some sort of
adrenaline spiking behavior
as you taper out of that stressful period,
not going strictly to massage, vacation,
and yoga nidra all day long,
as I would reflexively do.
"Can red light therapy help
treat exercise intolerance
and fatigue in mitochondrial disease?"
Allison, I'm glad you brought this up.
This is another case where I thought,
"Oh no, this red light stuff is crazy."
And then I went into the
literature and it turns out
that in 1908, the Nobel
Prize was actually given
for phototherapy.
So, there we go again.
And I have this slide,
I chose not to use slides tonight,
but I have this slide that shows Ken Kesey
and the magic bus and
stuff from the 1930s,
and psychedelics and people
getting into cold water.
And then here we are, 2019,
2020, you've got Wim Hof,
and Matt Johnson giving people
macro doses of psilocybin.
We're right back where we were.
And one of my major goals is to really try
and create some scientific
discussion around these things.
This stuff is crazy on the face of it,
but there are mechanisms that
are real that underlie it.
Red light, because it's
long wavelength light,
longer literally as opposed
to a short wavelength light,
can penetrate through things like skin
and can indeed change mitochondria.
One of the more impressive
results on red light
comes from my good
friend, Glen Jeffery's Lab
at the University College London.
I've known Glen for years,
and a few years, he was
a basic vision scientist.
And a few years ago he
started using red light.
He'd have people look at red light
at a distance of about
two feet in the morning.
So is long wavelength light.
And sometimes even just take a flashlight,
a torch as they call it in England,
and cover it with a red film.
And they would look at this stuff
for a few minutes each morning,
and it can reverse some forms
of age-related vision loss
and macular degeneration.
How we now know it can
prove mitochondrial function
in photoreceptors by
reducing what are called
reactive oxygen species.
Here's what's interesting,
it only seems to work
in people older than 40,
and it seems to only
work if you do it within
the first three hours of waking.
And the incredible
thing is you can do this
for one or two minutes a week,
and some of the positive effects last
as long as three weeks.
And it's affecting a very specific form
of visual improvement, which is acuity,
kind of fine detail stuff
in a particular wavelength.
So, particular colors
and objects and things.
Pretty impressive.
So, yes, red light can
improve mitochondrial function
to the photo receptors.
If you are going to try and do this stuff,
don't put it too close.
I don't have any affiliation
to any red light panel company.
So I can't say anything there.
They are rather expensive.
Nowadays, people are putting
red light everywhere,
and I do mean everywhere.
People are putting red
light on their stomach
for improving ovarian function,
whether or not it can
penetrate isn't clear to me
all the way down there.
People are trying to do this.
I have a friend, I won't name him.
Recently, he told me he is really into
the red light therapy.
He's putting it on his testicles
to try and increase testosterone.
But he told me that after
he handed me the red light.
[audience laughing]
True story.
My team knows who this is.
It's no one on my team.
Thank goodness.
I was like, "Oh, that's
super interesting."
I actually don't think you
want to contact the red lights
directly to your skin.
So red light is powerful.
I don't think we have, aside
from the vision protocol,
I don't think that it's clear
which protocols are best.
I will say if you're into
red light infrared sauna.
Typically those don't get hot enough.
Typically if you want to
get the benefits of sauna,
you want to get between 80
and 100 degrees Celsius,
which is 176 to 210 or 208 Fahrenheit.
And I don't actually do
the conversion in my head.
I memorize it.
"You mentioned the consequences
of blasting your brain
with too much dopamine.
Is it possible to overdo
ice baths while following
the same line of thinking?
Will you experience an
extreme low in dopamine
with too many ice baths?"
Lucas Ancke, thank you for the question.
Any behavior that spikes adrenaline,
you will eventually get
better at tolerating it.
You will become cold adapted
and you'll become comfortable
at high adrenaline states.
And you just have to ask yourself this,
it's just like lifting
weights in the gym or running.
You need to leave some
space for improvement.
So if you run, as people do,
and you do your 5k, then you're 10k,
then you're half marathon,
maybe a 10k is a half marathon.
I don't know.
But anyway, then you're
doing your marathon.
Then you're doing ultras that
are 50 miles and 100 miles.
I mean, eventually you're going
to start doing damage, right?
And eventually you look
at every ultra runner
and typically these are
people who are very much
on the dopamine pursuit system.
I mean, I don't think that he would mind;
my good friend and a podcaster
who I have tremendous
respect for is Rich Roll,
amazing human being,
and also has an amazing
story about addiction.
He was an alcoholic.
And I'm not sharing anything
that he hasn't already shared
in his amazing book, "Finding Ultra."
He got really into running,
running, running all the time
and there's a dopamine
history there for him.
Some of us can use ice
baths so consistently
and making it so cold and
doing them longer and longer
that indeed you're playing
with the dopamine system.
Is it bad?
Well, it depends on what
you're trading that in for,
at the expense of what?
Is it giving up cocaine?
Yeah, great, stick with the ice bath.
But you know, can only make it so cold
and you can only stay in there so long
before you become Wim Hof, right?
And it worked out for Wim,
but there's really only one Wim Hof.
And in general, that
speaks to a larger theme,
which is I love the idea
of people using tools
and understanding mechanism.
I mean, of course I love that.
It's what I talk about and
think about so much in my life.
But for most of us,
we don't make a living doing those things.
And so I do think that the ideal situation
is to have behaviors and
tools that you intersperse
throughout your day and
throughout the week.
For instance, I think
three times a week is fine
for the ice bath.
No one said you had to do it every day,
but you should see sunlight
every morning if you can.
Just because if you miss a
day, your system will be fine,
just spend twice as long
outside the next day.
Seriously, 'cause it's a
slow integrating system.
But for most of these
high intensity things,
the less often you do them,
the more powerful they are.
In fact, if you get into a very hot sauna
for four 30 minute sessions on one day.
So you go 30 minutes,
get out for five minutes.
30 minutes, get out for five minutes.
30 minutes, get out for five.
Two hours a day in the
sauna, that's a lot of sauna,
but the growth hormone release
from that type of protocol
is a 16x increase in growth hormone.
This has been measured in humans.
Whereas if you do it every day
or three or four times a week,
you get diminishing returns on that.
So I actually am a big fan
of doing really intense stuff
only every once in a while.
This is also why I only
take one long run per week
or one long hike.
First of all, I don't have time for it.
I'm not an ultra runner.
I got other things to do.
And second of all, it's a strong stimulus.
I'm sore until Tuesday,
or I don't want to run
until Tuesday anyway.
I actually think that's fine.
And I actually encourage
kind of more healthy,
rational schedules of
these kinds of behaviors.
There's no rule that says
you have to do something
every day, even if you're trying
to engage neuroplasticity.
You can learn French or an
instrument by practicing
three times a week.
As long as your practice
is very focused, right?
Daily perhaps would be better,
but very few of us have the opportunity
to do things every day consistently.
And I really want to encourage
a more balanced approach.
"Before working for
Thrasher, what's the best..."
Oh, goodness gracious.
The skateboarders are always in the house.
My first non-biological family
was a skateboarding community.
When I have great relationship
with my parents now,
but because there was a
time when there was no one
to go to soccer games
or do any of that stuff,
the skateboard community took me in
'cause there were no parents involved.
It was great.
There were no referees or coaches
'cause I didn't like
authority and it was awesome.
And there was no nutritional plan.
You drank your slurpy
and you sat on the curb,
and it was fantastic.
I don't do that anymore.
But the skateboarding community's
one that I've remained close with.
I did write for Thrasher
under a different name
while I was a postdoc
to make some extra cash.
You won't find those
articles anywhere, I hope.
They're not very good.
And the best skate trick?
Well, I was involved in it
enough that this will only
makes sense like three
people in the audience,
but I had decent heel flip.
I could nollie better than I could ollie.
And I was never very good.
Oh, there's more
skateboarders in the audience.
What I will say though,
is you have to be very
careful with skateboarders,
'cause I don't want to
claim that I was any good.
Any success that I had was
out of sympathy of others
for letting me hang around.
It's a great community.
And it gave me great
appreciation for indeed
communities of kids that
don't have structure
and sports leagues and teams
and all that kind of stuff.
Nowadays, it's actually a
much different landscape.
And I have to also say that
it's really amazing to see
all the incredible girls and
women skateboarders also.
There were none.
It's an Olympic sport
now for women and girls,
and it's an Olympic sport
for boys of men too.
So, it's awesome to see that community.
Okay, "What are your favorite brain hacks
for doing hard things?
Ranging from cold exposure to
getting through selection?"
Hoby Darling, thanks for the question.
Yeah, hard things.
Well, I'll be honest.
I learned how to hack
into my adrenaline system
a long time ago through the
worst possible mechanism,
which is that I would set
up battles in my mind.
I would get into competition
with people, imagined or real,
or I would get into states of
fearing shame and screwing up.
So, this is what a lot
of people do I think,
you end up scaring
yourself into trying to do
the hard thing, and it works.
The problem is it feels
rather like a downward spiral
because those negative states of mind
work to liberate adrenaline and
get you through hard things.
So being a kind of rebellious
kid, resistance was...
If someone told me I couldn't
do something, I was like,
"Yeah, try me" and this kind of thing.
And as I mentioned before, I
wasn't crazy about authority.
And so, that was the
method for a long time.
And then, I started reading
Oliver Sacks's books
and I started learning
from people who seemed
to access things through
this whole love thing.
And I tried that love and
kindness meditation thing,
and that didn't work.
And what I started doing was I actually,
I'll just tell you before
I came out here tonight
and before I do anything challenging,
I just actually like to imagine the people
that have supported me.
It's a weird tool.
I don't think I've ever shared.
I'm actually slightly
embarrassed to share this out.
'Cause there are only two
things that make me cry,
and that's talking about my bulldog
and talking about my graduate advisor.
And if I talk it about any
longer, I'll probably cry.
But I think about them a lot
because they were kind of similar.
They were kind of ornery
and they were hard on me,
and I adored them both.
And so these days I try
and think about people
that really, that I love.
And so I have been trying
to do this whole, like,
doing things from a place of love thing.
And so, for me, that's animals
and people that I love.
And okay, now, I better move on.
Ah, thank you.
[audience applauding]
Okay, they're telling
me one more question.
So I'm going to answer one more.
"What do I fear?
How do you manage your fear?"
KB, oh, gosh.
This is going to turn into a
no one's going to be satisfied
until I cry.
I get it, I get it.
[audience laughing]
I do cry, but again about the
things I mentioned before.
I realized something, by the way.
We just recorded an episode on grief.
It hasn't come out yet.
Fascinating topic.
I realized at one point, by the way,
I'll just give this away,
that I thought I was really
sad about losing them.
I thought I would tear up really easily
because I was sad about them.
But then I realized that this,
gosh, I can't believe
I'm going to do this.
But I realized that
feeling that I was feeling
is the exact same feeling of love
that I had when they were alive.
So, grief is love.
And when you look at the literature,
it's basically that, but
your brain is freaking out
because that map of knowing
where people are in space
and time, grief is basically
a remapping of the space:
Where are they?
Time: When are they?
And then, this kind of
abstract map representation
that we call closeness.
And grief is this process of
ripping ourselves off of that.
So, in any event, what do I fear?
Talking about things like this.
What do I fear?
Quite honestly, my biggest fear,
the thing that would just
make me feel just horrible
is I fear letting down my friends.
I have an amazing...
I love my family and they're wonderful,
but I have this incredible
relationship to friendship,
and I adore my friends
and I would sooner give up
all my limbs and die before I would
deliberately let them down.
So, there you go, that's what I fear most.
[audience applauding]
Thank you.
I also fear I've gone long.
And so my team has shut this down.
I just want to just briefly, two things.
First of all, I of course
want to thank everyone
for coming here tonight.
I realize it's the middle of the week
and to commit some hours of your life
to thinking about these brain mechanisms,
we got pretty nerdy there for a minute,
and hopefully the tools redeemed those
who were only interested
or mostly interested
in practical tools,
but hopefully some of the
insights about how you work
were useful as well.
I do want to just make brief
mention of the sponsors
that made this possible, 'cause
they did make this possible.
And we made every effort to
try and keep the ticket prices
manageable for people.
And thanks to InsideTracker and Momentous
for making this possible.
And then, of course I
would be completely remiss
if I didn't say thank you
for your interest in science.
[audience applauding]
[audience cheering]
Thank you.
Oh, wow, thank you.
[light music]
Thanks so much.
Everyone be sure to get
home safely tonight.